- [Narrator] What those
characters are speaking
isn't gibberish.
It's actually a language called Dothraki,
and it was invented by
this guy, David Peterson,
in lovely Orange County, California.
David Peterson is what
we call a conlanger,
an inventor of languages.
- Conlanging is the intentional
creation of a full language,
creating its full grammar,
its full phonology,
its writing system if it has one,
and its entire lexicon.
- [Narrator] David has
written many languages,
but the first one he
wrote was back in 2000.
- [David] I was taking an
intro linguistics class
at UC Berkeley in 2000,
and it was just one day during class
I started scribbling on my
notes my very first language.
- [Narrator] He named
it after his girlfriend.
- Meg Davy.
- [Narrator] And according
to David himself.
- It's irredeemably awful,
it's just not worth even
considering anymore.
Everything I was doing with this language
was just kind of a
really fancy bizarre way
to speak English.
So I just kind of started
over and said, “Alright,
ground zero, how do I
be a language creator?”
- [Narrator] Before we move forward,
let's take a quick step
back and talk about
the godfather of modern conlanging:
J.R.R. Tolkien.
You probably know this name
because he's the author
of The Hobbit and Lord of the Rings.
He created 14 different languages
for use within Middle Earth.
- Quenya and Sindarin are
probably his most famous.
He was the very first
person that we know of
to create languages just for fun,
and we've been kind of
emulating him ever since.
(knocking)
- [Narrator] Now that
we've cleared that up
we can move forward.
(doorbell rings)
We're here in California
because we're curious
about what it takes to
create a successful language.
David's having two of his
friends who are also conlangers
come over and speak with us.
One of them brought ice cream.
We were gonna do this
outside but it's too hot
so we're gonna do it inside.
The three of them are talking about
how languages are created,
and they've come up with five steps.
Take it away guys.
- Oh.
So, alright.
- [David] A naturalistic
conlang needs five basic things.
- One.
The people.
- What they do, who their neighbors are.
- The second thing that
you're going to need
is a phonology or sound system.
- Do you have voiced and
voiceless consonants?
Do you have aspirated consonants?
- Three, words.
- All the nouns, all the
verbs, all the modifiers.
- Fourth, grammar.
- Which is the fun part.
- Finally, history.
- You need to know how meanings
of words changed over time
and you need to know how
the grammar of your language
evolved from a time in the distant past
to what's used now.
- [Narrator] Now that
we've got that settled,
let's finish this.
- In the past 15 years,
somebody who created language
went from somebody who's
like, oh, you're a nerd,
to, you know, oh wow.
That's really nerdy, which now means cool.
- [Narrator] And its prolific
use in television and film
proves that it's not just a passing fancy.
(speaking foreign language)
- For television the difference between
a created language and some other set prop
is that the maximum level of interaction
that a viewer ever has with a
background set or with a prop
is just seeing it on screen.
A language, on the other hand,
when you hear it that's the
most real a language ever gets.
For that reason you have to
have a fully created language
for a television show,
and not just a bunch of gibberish.
Was that good?
- That was great.
- Thank god.